[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN GORNER: Hi, everyone,
and thank you for being here
at 8:30 in the morning,
and welcome to this session
about TPUs and TPU pods.
So those are custom
made accelerators
that Google has designed to
accelerate machine learning
workloads.
And before I tell you everything
about them, me and Kaz,
I would like to do something.
Of course, this is live, so
you want to see a live demo.
And I would like to train
with you here, onstage, using
a TPU pod, one of
those big models
that used to take days to train.
And we'll see if we
can finish the training
within this session.
So let me start the training.
I will come back to explaining
exactly what I'm doing here.
I'm just starting it.
Run all cells.
Seems to be running.
OK, I'm just checking.
I'm running this on
a 128 core TPU pod.
So one of the things
you see in the logs here
is that I have all
my TPUs appearing.
0, 1, 2, 6, and all
the way down to 128.
All right, so this is running.
I'm happy with it.
Let's hear more about TPUs.
So first of all, what is
this piece of silicon?
And this is the demo
that I've just launched.
It's an object
detection demo that
is training on a wildlife
data set of 300,000 images.
Why wildlife?
Because I can show
you cute pandas.
And I can show you cute
electronics as well.
So this is a TPU v2.
And we have a second
version now, a TPU v3.
Those are fairly large boards.
It's large like this, roughly.
And as you can see, they
have four chips on them.
Each chip is dual core,
so each of these boards
has 8 TPU cores on them.
And each core has two units.
That is a vector
processing unit.
That is a fairly standard
data-oriented processor,
general purpose processor.
What makes this special
for machine learning
is the matrix multiply unit.
TPUs have a built-in
hardware-based matrix
multiplier that can multiply to
128 by 128 matrices in one go.
So what is special
about this architecture?
There are two
tricks that we used
to make it fast and efficient.
The first one is, I
would say, semi-standard.
It's reduced precision.
When you train neural networks,
reducing the precision
from 32-bit floating
points to 16-bit
is something that people
quite frequently do,
because neural networks are
quite resistant to the loss
of precision.
Actually, it even
happens sometimes
that the noise that is
introduced by reduced precision
acts as a kind of regularizer
and helps with convergence.
So sometimes you're even lucky
when you reduce precision.
But then, as you see on this
chart, float16 and float32,
the floating point formats,
they don't have the same number
of exponent bits,
which means that they
don't cover the same range.
So when you take a model and
downgrade all your float32s
into float16s, you might get
into underflow or overflow
problems.
And if it is your
model, it's usually not
so hard to go in and fix.
But if you're using
code from GitHub
and you don't know
where to fix stuff,
this might be very problematic.
So that's why on TPUs,
we chose a different--
actually we designed a
different floating point
format called bfloat16.
And as you can
see, it's actually
exactly the same as float32
with just the fractional bits
cut off.
So the point is it has
exactly the same number
of exponent bits,
exactly the same range.
And therefore, usually,
it's a drop-in replacement
for float32 and
reduced precision.
So typically for
you, there is nothing
to do on your model to benefit
from the speed of reduced
precision.
The TPU will do this
automatically, on ship,
in hardware.
And the second trick
is architectural.
It's the design of this
matrix multiply unit.
So that you understand
how this works,
try to picture, in your
head, how to perform a matrix
multiplication.
And one result, one
point of the resulting
matrix, try to remember calculus
from school, is a dot product.
A dot product of one line
of one matrix and one column
of the second matrix.
Now what is a dot product?
A dot product is a series of
multiply-accumulate operations,
which means that the
only operation you
need to perform a
matrix multiplication
is multiply and accumulate.
And multiply-accumulate
in 16 bits,
because we're using
bfloat16 reduced precision.
That is a tiny, tiny
piece of silicon.
A 16-bit multiply-accumulator
is a tiny piece of silicon.
And if you wire them together
as an array, as you see here.
So this in real life would
be a 128 by 128 array.
It's called a systolic array.
Systolic in Greek means flow.
Because you will flow
the data through it.
So the way it works is that you
load one matrix into the array,
and then you flow the second
matrix through the array.
And you'll have to
believe me, or maybe
spend a little bit more
time with the animation,
by the time the gray
dots have finished
flowing through those
multiply-accumulators,
out of the right side come
all the dot products that
make the resulting matrix.
So it's a one-shot operation.
There are no intermediate values
to store anywhere, in memory,
in registers.
All the intermediate
values flow on the wires
from one compute unit to
the second compute units.
It's very efficient.
And what is more,
it's only made of
those tiny 16-bit
multiply-accumulators,
which means that we can cram
a lot of those into one chip.
128 by 128 is 16,000
multiply-accumulators.
And that's how much you get
in one TPU core, twice that
in two TPU cores.
So this is what makes it dense.
Density means power efficiency.
And power efficiency in
the data center means cost.
And of course, you
want to know how cheap
or how fast these things are.
Some people might
remember from last year
I did a talk about what I
built, this planespotting model,
so I'm using this as
a benchmark today.
And on Google
Cloud's AI platform,
it's very easy to get
different configurations,
so I can test how
fast this trains.
My baseline is-- on a
fast GPU, this model
trains in half in
four and a half hours.
But I can also get 5
machines with powerful GPUs
in a cluster.
And on those five
machines, five GPUs,
this model will
train in one hour.
And I've chosen this number
because one hour is exactly
the time it takes for this
model to train on one TPU v2.
So the rule of thumb
I want you to remember
is that roughly 1 TPU
v2, with its 4 chips,
is roughly as fast as
five powerful GPUs.
That's in terms of speed.
But as you can see, it's
almost three times cheaper.
And that's the point of
optimizing the architecture
specifically for neural
network workloads.
You might want to know how
this works in software as well.
So when you're using TensorFlow,
or Keras in TensorFlow,
your Python code
TensorFlow Python code
generates a computational graph.
That is how TensorFlow works.
So your entire neural network
is represented as a graph.
Now, this graph is what
is sent to the TPU.
Your TPU does not
execute Python code.
This graph is processed through
XLA, the Accelerated Linear
Algebra compiler,
and that is how
it becomes TPU microcode
to be executed on the TPU.
And one nice side-effect
of this architecture
is that if, in your
TensorFlow code,
you load your data through
the standard tf.data.Dataset
API, as you should, and as
is required with TPUs, then
even the data loading part, or
imagery resizing, or whatever
is in your data pipeline,
ends up in the graph,
ends up executed on the TPU.
And the TPU will be pulling
data from Google Cloud Storage
directly during training.
So that is very efficient.
How do you actually
write this with code?
So let me show you in Keras.
And one caveat, this is
Keras in TensorFlow 1.14,
which should be out
in these next days.
The API is slightly
different in TensorFlow 1.13
today, but I'd rather show
you the one that will be--
the new one, as of
tomorrow or next week.
So it's only a couple
of lines of code.
There is the first line,
TPUClusterResolver.
You can call it without
parameters on most platforms,
and that finds
the connected TPU.
The TPU is a
remotely-connected accelerator.
This finds it.
You initialize the TPU and then
you use the new distribution
API in TensorFlow to define a
TPU strategy based on this TPU.
And then you say
with strategy.scope,
and everything that follows is
perfectly normal Keras code.
Then you define your
model, you compile it,
you do model.fit,
model.evaluate, model.predict,
anything you're used
to doing in Keras.
So in Keras, it's literally
these four lines of code
to add--
to work on a TPU.
And I would like to point out
that these four lines of code
also transform your model
into a distributed model.
Remember a TPU,
even a single GPU,
is a board with eight cores.
So from the get go it's
distributed computing.
And these four lines
of code put in place
all the machinery of
distributed computing for you.
One parameter to notice.
You see in the TPU
strategy, there
is the steps_per_run equals 100.
So that's an optimization.
This tells the TPU, please run
100 batches worth of training
and don't report back
until you're finished.
Because it's a network
attached accelerator,
you don't want the TPU
to be reporting back
after each batch for
performance reasons.
So this is the software.
If you don't want to
write your own code,
I encourage you to do so.
But if you don't, we
have a whole library
of TPU optimized models.
So you will find them on
the TensorFlow/tpu GitHub
repository.
And there is everything
in the image--
in the vision space, in
the machine translation,
and language, and NLP space,
in speech recognition.
Even you can play
with GaN models.
The one that we are
demoing on stage,
remember we are training the
model right now, is RetinaNet.
So this one is an
object detection model.
And I like this model,
so let me say a few words
about how this works.
In object detection, you put
an image, and what you get
is not just the label--
this is a dog, this is a panda--
but you actually get boxes
around where those objects are.
In object detection
models, you have two kinds.
There are one shot
detectors that
are usually fast but
kind of inaccurate,
and then two-stage
detectors that are much more
accurate but much slower.
And I like RetinaNet
because they actually
found a trick to make
this both the fastest
and the most accurate
model that you can
find in object detection today.
And it's a very simple trick.
I'm not going to explain
all the math behind it,
but basically in these
detection models,
you start with
candidate detections.
And then you prune them to
find only the detections--
the boxes that have
actual objects in them.
And the thing is that all
those blue boxes that you see,
there is nothing in them.
So even during training,
they will very easily
be classified as nothing
to see, move along boxes,
with a fairly small error.
But you've got
loads of them, which
means that when you compute the
loss of this model, in the loss
you have a huge sum
of very small errors.
And that huge sum of very
small errors might in the end
be very big and overwhelm
the useful signal.
So the two-stage
detectors resolve that
by being much more careful
about those candidate boxes.
In one-stage
detectors, you start
with a host of candidate boxes.
And the trick they
found in RetinaNet
is a little mathematical
trick on the loss
to make sure that the
contribution of all
those easy boxes stays small.
The upshot, it's both
fast and accurate.
So let me go back here.
I actually want to say a word
about now what I did, exactly,
when I launched this demo.
I guess most of you are familiar
with the Google Cloud Platform.
So here I am opening the
Google Cloud Platform console.
And in the Google
Cloud Platform,
I have a tool called
AI platform, which,
for those who know it, has had
a facility for running training
jobs and for deploying
models behind the REST API
for serving.
But there is a new
functionality called Notebooks.
In AI platform, you can today
provision ready all-installed
notebook for working in--
yeah, so let me
switch to this one--
for working either
in TensorFlow,
in PyTorch, with GPUs.
It's literally a
one click operation.
NEW INSTANCE, I want
a TensorFlow instance
with Jupyter notebook
installed, and what you get
is here an instance that is
running but with the link
to open Jupyter.
For example, this one--
and it will open Jupyter,
but it's already open.
So it's asking me to select
something else, but it's here.
And here, you can
actually work normally
in your Jupyter environment
with a powerful accelerator.
You might have noticed
that I don't have a TPU
option, actually
not here, but here,
for adding an accelerator.
That's coming.
But here I am using
Jupyter notebook instances
that are powered by a
TPU v3 128-core pod.
How did I do it?
It's actually possible
on the command line.
I give you the
command line here.
There is nothing fancy about it.
There is one gcloud
compute command line
to start to the instance and a
second gcloud compute command
line to start the TPU.
You provision a TPU just as
you would a virtual machine
in Google's cloud.
So this is what I've done.
And that is what is
running right now.
So let's see if what we are.
Here it's still running.
As you see enqueue
next 100 batches.
And it's training.
We are step 4,000
out of 6,000 roughly.
So we'll check back on this
demo at the end of the session.
This demo, when I was doing
it, to run it on stage,
I've been able also to run a
comparison between how fast our
TPU v3s versus v2s.
In theory, v3s are roughly
twice as powerful as v2s,
but that only works if
you feed them enough
work to make use of
all the hardware.
So here on RetinaNet,
you can train
on images of various sizes.
Of course, if you train
on smaller images, 256
pixel images, it
will be much faster,
in terms of images per second.
And I've tried both--
TPU v2s and v3s.
You see with small images,
you get a little bump
in performance from TPU v3s,
but nowhere near double.
But as you get to bigger
and bigger images,
you are feeding the
hardware with more work.
And on 640 pixel images, the
speed up you get from TPU v3
is getting close to the
theoretical x2 factor.
So for this reason, I am
running this demo here
at the 512 pixel image
size on a TPU v3 pod.
I'm talking about pods.
But what are these
pods, exactly?
To show you more
about TPU pods, I
would like to give
the lectern to Kaz.
Thank you Kaz.
KAZ SATO: Thank you, Martin.
[APPLAUSE]
So in my part, I directly
introduce Cloud TPU pods.
What are pods?
It's a large cluster
of Cloud TPUs.
The version two pod is now
available as public beta, which
provides 11.6 petaflops,
with 512 TPU cores.
The next generation
version three pod
is also public beta
now, which achieves
over 100 petaflops
with 2,048 TPU cores
So those performance numbers
are as high as the greatest
supercomputers.
So Cloud TPU pods
are AI supercomputer
that Google have
built from scratch.
But some of you
might think, what's
the difference between a bunch
of TPU instances and a Cloud
TPU pod?
The difference is
the interconnect.
Google has developed ultra
high-speed interconnect
hardware derived from a
supercomputer technology,
for connecting thousands of
TPUs with very short latency.
What does it do for you?
As you can see on the
animation, every time you update
a single parameter
on a single TPU,
that will be synchronized
with all the other thousands
of TPUs, in an instant,
by the hardware.
So in short, TensorFlow
users can use the whole pod
as a single giant
machine with thousands
of TPU cores inside it.
It's as easy as using
a single computer.
And you may wonder, because
it's an AI supercomputer,
you may also take
super high cost.
But it does not.
You can get started
with using TPU pods
with 32 cores at $24 per hour,
without any initial cost.
So you don't have to
pay millions of dollars
to build your own
supercomputer from scratch.
You can just rent it for a
couple of hours from the cloud.
Version three pod also can
be provisioned with 32 cores.
That costs only $32 per hour.
For larger sizes, you can
ask our service contact
for the pricing.
What is the cost benefit
of a TPU pods over GPUs?
Here's a comparison result.
With a full version two pod,
with 512 TPU cores, you can
train the same ResNet-50 models
at 27 times faster
speed at 38% lower cost.
This shows the clear
advantage of the TPU pods
to a typical
GPU-based solutions.
And there are other benefits
you could get from the TPU pods.
Let's take a look
at eBay's case.
eBay has over 1 billion
product listings.
And to make it easier to
search specific products
from 1 billion products, they
built a new visual search
feature.
And to train the models, they
have used 55 million images.
So it's a really large
scale training for them.
And they have used
Cloud TPU pods, and eBay
was able to get a 100
times faster training time,
compared with
existing GPU service.
And they will also get
a 10% accuracy boost.
Why is that?
TPU itself is not designed
to increase the accuracy
that much.
But because if you can't
increase the training speed
10 times or 100 times,
that means the data
scientists or researchers can
have 10 times 100 times more
iterations for the
trials, such as trying out
a different combination
of the hyperparameters
or different
preprocessings and so on.
So that ended up at least 10%
accuracy boost in eBay's case.
Let's see what kind
of TensorFlow code
you would write to get those
benefits from TPU pods.
And before taking a
look at the actual code,
I try to look back.
What are the efforts
required, in the past,
to implement the large
scale distributed training?
Using many GPUs or TPUs
for a single machine
running training, that is
so-called distributed training.
And there are two ways.
One is data parallel and
another is model parallel.
Let's talk about the
data parallel first.
With data parallel, as you
can see on the diagram,
you have to split the training
data into the multiple GPU
or TPU nodes.
And also you have to share the
same parameter set, the model.
And to do that, you have to set
up a cluster of GPUs or TPUs
by yourself.
And also you have to set
up a parameter server that
shares all the updates
of our parameters
among all the GPU or TPUs.
So it's a complex setup.
And also in many
cases, you have to--
there's going to be
synchronization overhead.
So if you have hundreds
or as thousands
of the TPUs or GPUs
in a single cluster,
that's going to be a
huge overhead for that.
And that limits the scalability.
But with TPU pods, the
hardware takes care of it.
Your high-speed
interconnect synchronizes
all of the parameter
updates in a single TPU
with the other thousands
of TPUs in an instant,
with very short latency.
So there's no need to set
up the parameter server,
or there's no need to set
up the large cluster of GPUs
by yourself.
And also you can get
almost linear scalability
to add more on the more
TPU cores in your training.
And Martin will show you
the actual scalability
result later.
And as I mentioned
earlier, TensorFlow users
can use the whole TPU pods
as a single giant computer
and with thousands of
TPU cores inside it.
So it's as easy as
using a single computer.
For example, if you have Keras
code running on a single TPU,
it also runs on a 2,000 TPU
cores without any changes.
This is exactly the same
code Martin showed earlier.
So under the hood, all the
complexity for the data
parallel training, such
as splitting the training
data into the multiple
TPUs, or the sharing
the same parameters,
those are all
taken care of by the
TPU pods' interconnect,
and XLA compilers, and
the new TPUStrategy
API in the TensorFlow 1.14.
The one thing you may want
to change is the batch size.
As Martin mentioned, a TPU
core has a matrix processor
that has 128 by 128
matrix multipliers.
So usually, you will
get the best performance
by setting in the batch size
to 128 times the number of TPU
cores.
So if you have 10 TPU cores,
that's going to be 1,280.
The benefit of TPU pods is
not only the training times.
It also enables the
training of giant modules
by using gear the
Mesh TensorFlow.
Data parallel has been a popular
way of distributed training,
but there's one downside.
It cannot train a big model.
Because all departments are
shared with all the GPUs
or TPUs, you cannot bring a
big model that doesn't fit
into the memory of a
single GPU or a TPU.
So there's another way of
distributed training called
a model parallel.
With model parallel, you
can split the giant model
into the multiple GPUs
or TPUs so that you
can train much larger models.
But that has not
been a popular way.
Why?
Because it's much
harder to implement.
As you can see on
the diagrams, you
have to implement all
the communications
between the fraction
of the models.
It's like stitching
between the models.
And again, you have to set
up the complex cluster,
and in many cases,
the communication
between the models.
Because if you have
hundreds of thousands
of CPU or GPU or TPU
cores, then that's
going to be a huge
overhead for that.
So those are the reasons
why model parallel has not
been so popular.
To solve those problems,
TensorFlow team
has developed a new library
called Mesh TensorFlow.
It's a new way of
distributed training,
with the multiple
computing nodes,
such as TPU pods, or multiple
GPUs, or multiple CPUs.
TensorFlow provides
an abstraction layer
that sees those computing nodes
as a logical n-dimensional
mesh.
Mesh TensorFlow is now
available as open source
code on the TensorFlow
GitHub repository.
To see how it
works with imaging,
you could have a
simple neural network
like this for recognizing
the MNIST model.
This network has the
batch size as 512,
and data dimension as
784, and one hidden layer
with 100 nodes, and
output as 10 classes.
And if you want to train
that network with the model
parallel, you can
just specify, I
want to split the parameters
into four TPUs to the Mesh
TensorFlow, and that's it.
You don't have to
think about how
to implement the communication
between the split model
and how to worry about the
communication overhead.
What kind of a code
you would write?
Here is the code to
use the model parallel.
At first, you have to
define the dimensions
of both data and the model.
In this code, you are defining
the batch dimension as 512,
and the data has
a 784 dimensions,
and hidden layer has 100
nodes, and the 10 classes.
And then you define
your own network
by using Mesh TensorFlow APIs,
such as two sets of weights
and one hidden layers, and
one logits and loss function,
by using those dimensions.
Finally, you define how many
TPU or GPUs have in the mesh,
and what is the layout
rule you want to use.
In this code example, it
is defining a hidden layer
dimensions for splitting the
model parameters into the four
TPUs.
And that's it.
So that the Mesh TensorFlow
can take a look at this code
and automatically split the
model parameters into the four
TPUs.
And it shares the same training
data with all the TPUs.
You can also combine both
data and the model parallel.
For example, you can define
the 2D mesh like this.
And you use the rows of the
mesh for the data parallel
and use the column of the
mesh or the model parallel,
so that you can get the
benefits from both of them.
And again, it's easy to
define with Mesh TensorFlow.
You can just specify
batch dimension
for the rows and hidden layer
dimensions for the columns.
This is an example where
you are using the Mesh
TensorFlow for training
a transformer model.
Transformer model is a very
popular language model,
and I don't go deeper into
the transformer model.
But as you can see,
it's so easy to map
each layer of a
transformer model
to the layer load
of Mesh TensorFlow
so that you can efficiently map
the large data and large model
into the hundreds of
thousands of TPU cores
by using Mesh TensorFlow.
So what's the benefit?
By using the Mesh TensorFlow
running with to TPU pods,
the Google AI team was able
to train the language module
and translation model with
the billion word scale.
And they were able to achieve
the state-of-the-art scores,
as you can see on those numbers.
So for those use cases, the
larger the model, the better
accuracy you get.
The model parallel with TPU
pods give the big advantage
on achieving those
state-of-the-art scores.
Let's take a look at another use
case of the large scale model
parallel I just call BigGAN.
And I don't go deeper into what
is GAN or how the GAN works.
But here's the basic idea.
You have the two
defined networks.
One is called
discriminator D and another
is called generator G. And
you define a loss function
so that the D to be trained to
recognize whether an image is
a fake image or real image.
And at the same time, the
generator will be trained
to generate a realistic
image so that a D cannot find
it's a fake.
It's like a minimax game you
are playing with those two
networks.
And eventually, you
will have a generic G
that can generate a
photo-realistic fake images,
artificial images.
Let's take a look
at the demo video.
So this is not big spoiler.
I have already loaded
the bigger models
that is trained on the TPU pod.
And as you can
see, these are all
the artificial synthesized
image at high quality.
You can also
specify the category
of the generated
images, such as ostrich,
so that you can generate
the ostrich images.
These are all synthesized
artificial images.
None of them are real.
And because BigGAN can have
the so-called latent space that
has the seeds to
generate those images,
you can interpolate
between two seeds.
In this example,
it is interpolating
between golden
retriever and Lhasa.
And you can try out a
different combination
of the interpolation, such as
west highland white terrier
and golden retriever.
Again, those are
all fake images.
So this bigger model was trained
with the TPU version three
pod with 512 cores.
And that took 24
hours to 48 hours.
Why BigGAN takes so many
TPU cores and so long time?
The reasons are the model
size and the batch size.
The quality of a GAN model,
measured by GAN model,
are measured by the
inception score, or IS score.
That represents how
much an inception model
thinks those images are real.
And that also represents the
variety of generated images.
The BigGAN paper
says that you get
better IS score
when you are having
more parameters in
the model and when
you are using the larger
batch size for the training.
So that means the larger
scale model parallel
on the hundreds of TPU cores
is crucial for BigGAN model
to increase the quality
of those generated images.
So we have seen two use cases.
A BigGAN use case and
language model use cases.
And those are the first
applications of the model
parallel on TPU pods.
But they are only the starters.
So TPU pods are available
to everyone from now.
So we expect to see
more and more exciting
use cases coming from
the new TPU pods users
and also from the applications.
So that's it for my part.
Back to Martin.
MARTIN GORNER: So now it's
time to check on our demo.
Did our model actually train?
Checking here, yeah, it looks
like it has finished training.
A saved model has been saved.
So the only thing
that is to do is
to verify if this model can
actually predict something.
So on a second machine I will
reload the exact same model.
OK.
I believe that's the one.
And let's go and reload it.
So I'll skip training
this time and just go here
to inference and loading.
Whoops, sorry about that.
I just hope the demo gods
will be with me today.
All right.
That's because I'm loading
the wrong directory.
The demo gods are
almost with me.
It's this one where my
model has been saved.
All right.
Yes.
Indeed.
It wasn't the same.
Sorry about that.
No training, just inference.
And this time, it looks
like my model is loading.
And once it's loaded, I
will see if it can actually
detect animals in
images, and here we are.
So this leopard is
actually a leopard.
This bird is a bird.
The lion is a lion.
This is a very tricky image.
So I'm showing you not
cherry-picked images.
This is a model I have trained
on stage, here with you.
No model is perfect.
We will see bad
detections, like this one.
But that's a tricky one.
It's artwork.
It's not an actual lion.
The leopard is spot on.
The lion is spot on.
And see that the boxing
actually works very well.
The leopard has been perfectly
identified in the image.
So let's move to something
more challenging.
Even this inflatable artwork
lion has been identified,
which is not always the case.
This is a complicated image--
a flock of birds.
So you see it's not
seeing all of them.
But all of them at
least are birds,
which is a pretty good job.
The leopard is fine.
Oh, and this is the
most complex we have.
There is a horse and cattle.
Well, we start seeing a
couple of bad detections here.
Of course, that
cow is not a pig.
As I said, no model is perfect.
But here the tiger
is the tiger, and we
have our two cute pandas.
And those two cute pandas
are actually quite difficult,
because those are baby pandas.
And I don't believe
that this model
has had a lot of baby animals
in its 300,000 images data set.
So I'm quite glad that it
managed to find the two pandas.
So moving back, let me
finish by giving you
a couple of feeds and
speeds on those models.
So here, this model has
a RetinaNet 50 backbone,
plus all the detection layers
that produced the boxes.
And we have been training it
on a TPU v3 pod with 128 cores.
It did finish in 20 minutes.
You don't have to just
believe me for that.
Let me show you.
Here I had a timer
read my script.
Yep, 19 minutes and 18 seconds.
So I'm not cheating.
This was live.
But I could also have run
this model on a smaller pod.
Actually, I tried
on a TPU v2-32.
On this chart, you see
the speed on this axis
and the time on this axis.
This is to show you that
a TPU v2-32 is actually
a very useful tool to have.
We've been talking about
huge models up to now.
But it's debatable whether
this is a huge model.
This definitely was a
huge model a year ago.
Today, with better
tools, I can train it
in an hour on a fairly
modest TPU v2 32-core pod.
So even as an individual
data scientist,
that is a very useful tool
for me to have handy when
I need to do a round of
trainings on a model like this,
because someone wants an
animal detection model.
And bringing the training
down to the one hour
space, or 20 minutes
space, allows
me to work a lot faster
and iterate a lot faster
on the hyperparemeters, on
the fine tuning, and so on.
You see on a single TPU
v3, it's the bottom line.
And if we were to
train this on a GPU--
so remember our rule of
thumb from the beginning.
One TPU v2, roughly five GPUs.
Therefore 1 TPU v3,
roughly 10 GPUs.
So the GPU line would be
one tenth of the lowest
line on this graph.
I didn't put it because it
would barely register there.
That shows you the
change of scale
at which you can be training
your models using TPUs.
You might be
wondering about this.
So as you scale, one
thing that might happen
is that you have to adjust
your learning rate schedule.
So this is actually the
learning rate schedule
I have used to train the
model on the 128 core TPU pod.
Just a couple of words,
because it might not
be the most usual learning rate
schedule you have ever seen.
There is this ramp up.
So the second part
is exponential decay.
That's fairly standard.
But the ramp up part,
that is because we
are starting from
ResNet-50, initialized
with pre-trained weights.
But we still leave
those weights trainable.
So we are training
the whole thing.
It's not transfer learning.
It's just fine tuning of
pre-trained ResNet-50.
And when you do
that, and you train
very fast, using big
batches, as we do here,
the batch size here
is 64 times 128.
So it's a very big batch size.
You might actually break
those pre-trained weights
in ways that harm
your precision.
So that's why it's quite
usual to have a ramp up period
to make sure that the network,
in its initial training
phases, when it doesn't
know what it's doing,
does not completely
destroy the information
in the pre-trained weights.
So we did it.
We did train this model
here on stage in 20 minutes.
And the demo worked, I'm
really glad about that.
So this is the end.
What we have seen is
TPUs and TPU pods.
Fast, yes.
But mostly cost effective.
Very cost effective
way and a good tool
to have for any data scientist.
Also, and more specifically
for very large models,
but for what used to be
large models in the past
and which are normal models
today, such as a ResNet-50
[INAUDIBLE].
It's a very useful tools.
And then Cloud TPU pods,
where you can actually
enable not only data,
but model parallelism,
using this new library
called Mesh TensorFlow.
A couple of links here
with more information
if you would like to know more.
Yes, you can take a picture.
And if you have
more questions, we
will be at the AI
ML pod, the red one,
in front of one TPU rack.
So you can see this
one live and get
a feel for what kind
of computer it is.
And with that,
thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]